hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
connections between duties right duties
could coincide you could have one a
action that you feel that you want to do
in a particular situation and it might
be motivated by the multiple duties so
he has an example here of Socrates and
credo which if you haven't read it's
worth worth reading yeah credo Socrates
says I have an obligation to maybe the
laws of my city what there's multiple
reasons so first off he says there's a
duty of gratitude
I've been able to live in this political
community for a long time I've done well
in it it's taken care of me it's made
you know civilized life possible for me
so therefore out of gratitude I have to
do the only thing I can really do you
know other than like trying to read
statues or something like that so I made
a lot of money I can obey the laws I can
actually do it what I'm supposed to do
as a citizen also there is a
professional duty
Fidelity this is the argument that he
makes he says by choosing to stay in
Athens when I could have gone other
places I made an implicit promise that I
would obey the laws by you know by
staying there and accepting the the
protection and the hospitality of the
laws I've put myself under an obligation
to actually obey them and then finally
he could be argued that there's also a
duty of beneficence maybe the laws are
actually potent instruments for the
common good you know for helping other
people there might be a duty of
malfeasance there too right if I break
the laws maybe I'm screwing somebody
else over damaging their property
they're there their person their
opportunities right so there could be
other duties there as well maybe
reparation if I've already broken the
laws now I have even stronger obligation
once I you know paid my my penalty to
actually follow laws maybe maybe that's
the case you've got another example
being in an economic or social system
that's been historically unjust in which
we participated maybe there is a duty of
Justice which is to distribute things
equally so you know are there are there
still people in our society who are have
screwed over because of who they are
let's think you know for example about
about education right K through 12
education are all high schools and
middle schools and elementary
why not and then I asked about the root
causes at this point just how are they
not equal at this how are they not yeah
all the teachers that's a big one I mean
some teachers you go in there and you're
like man these people should not be
teaching you know or they get burned out
my name my Aunt Mary was a Chicago
Public School teacher 35 years and still
teaches you know part-time some of the
stuff that goes on in the CPS just
amazing would not fly anywhere else you
know classrooms just packed full of kids
the teachers are not able to discipline
them you know because we're not allowed
to at all so you can imagine what
education is like in a situation like
that not a lot of it going up and
they're always playing catch-up what
else what else makes a good school or
pencil yeah
that's massive yeah we actually have a
band room here's another example from
from Marisa she taught several classes
in a locker room at academic classes not
gym classes academic classes because
they were out of space and she wasn't
just teaching him while the trailer is
out the parking lot I imagined you know
having to go to school in a trailer
I lived in a trailer for a while
anything like that I can't imagine
having 25 kids into a trailer now to
learn something not only did she
teaching it in a library she shared that
locker over three other team
to other teachers so there could be two
classes going on at the same time in a
gym locker you know with just a
partition now imagine trying to learn
something in a situation like that right
you know do you actually have last rooms
do you have the resources to allow
children to experiment to enrich their
lives with you know music art drama what
else do we tend to cut here in the
States
Jim programs unfortunately all these
kids you know well bit overweight right
should come gym classes that's a
no-brainer right there opportunities for
fuel trips you know that's probably a
you know enough now why are schools like
that what's the cost is this what you're
gonna you guys know what the main source
of funding for schools tends to be
federal government kicks in some money
state government kicks in some money
sometimes what's the biggest
the taxes yeah property taxes the
homeowner is in a given area are taxed
on the the values of their homes
whatever they happen to be a suspect
this is a constant source of aggravation
for people's local politics but that
money goes to fund the schools yeah you
know schools that are doing particularly
well it's fairly easy to make a case
where the property taxes should be up
there schools that are doing quite
poorly nobody wants to contribute to
them and so you get a situation where
it's a cycle all right
another thing that it also fits in their
alumni donations you know if you're a
school that tends to prepare its
students very well your your students
tend to do quite well once they get out
and they tend to be willing to put in a
run equipment system right whereas if
you're a school that's underperforming
you know one of the places that I taught
up for your graduation rate nine percent
nine percent of the students who who
came in actually graduated after four
years thirty percent graduated after six
years if you don't graduate after six
probably time you graduate now that
school didn't have a lot of alumni
donations you know why because the
Alumni don't tend to do too well they do
it's probably not so much for the school
itself it's from other stuff that they
did now if you're in a situation like
that
what sort of duties would would apply
for us as citizens maybe a promotion of
duty of justice maybe we look at that
and say hey that's not right
that's not fair you know it's not these
kids fault they they are you know
growing up in the wrong neighborhood why
should they be screwed because of that
why should these kids get it you know
all these advantages because they happen
to be in the right neighborhood that's
that's a sense of justice right
perhaps there's also a duty of
reparation in some cases we ought to
make these things right
plenty of other people in that screwed
for a long time and that's contributed
to though the kids who are doing poorly
right now I'm not alone by the way I'm
not politically a liberal but I
understand that I understand the
argument behind that sort of thing I can
find myself very sympathetically that
sort of notion because I've seen how
kids do when they have a bad educational
foundation you know this is really doing
harm to them what other what other
possible connections for there be
sometimes do these give rise to other
duties so you know if you fail in
certain duties like to give somebody an
unfair allotment then the duty of
reparations which are right or if you
make a promise of somebody and you break
your promise don't you have to make it
right afterwards it's not just
fulfilling what you ought to have done
maybe you should put something else on
top of that to make up for it does this
sound like something you can relate to
pretty easily
not enough seasons if you if you harm
somebody you ought to do something to
fix it for them right again if you knock
somebody's fence down maybe you fix
their fence right or you damage your
roommates
furniture maybe roof it refinishing it
right what else there's there's another
possible example justice and and
benevolence if you have a duty of
justice then you know you're supposed to
give everybody fair allotments of things
does that create another duty in the
term to keep on doing that
duty of fidelity Ross
you say yes think about I am this in the
handout for you you think about these in
this notion of paying it forward
what is that because I've heard that
expression before yeah not for the
person who did it for you originally
right yeah that's that's the whole idea
behind it is I help you up and then
there's I mean you could do something
nice for me and then go serve it would
be complete but it's better if you keep
the good acts flowing you know and
sometimes somebody'll say hey what can I
do for you in return and say just pay it
forward just just keep it keep it going
so you could think about this in terms
of the duty of gratitude all right you
feel gratitude and then act would give
rise to two other duties want to be
Podesta I I find that you're struggling
and in a particular class so I give you
a book that I found useful for myself
when I was a student struggling with
that same class and
what do you do with that boy you're
going to give the book back and said now
I keep the pay it forward right what do
you do you give that book to somebody
else that you see struggling with the
same thing you're doing in the act of
beneficent a duty of gratitude gives
rise to a duty of beneficence in that
case do you see how these come together
another way in which this could take
place that could also create duties
where you might actually out of duty
it's all a lot yeah
yeah that's perfect the surprise part
right
or a present that you know it takes a
little while to coordinate maybe it's a
trip to somewhere and you got to get
certain information from the person you
don't tell them what the information
this morning when they press you how do
you tell them it's about something else
I'm signing you up for some magazines
like that all right when really you're
doing to do something really nice for
them so that would be beneficence
beneficence and fidelity could conflict
with each other and what guidance does
Ross give you for this he says when I'm
in a situation in which more than one of
these prima facia duties is incumbent
upon me what I have to do is study the
situation as fully as I can they
actually pay attention to what's in the
situation look at it carefully don't try
to just solve it to get it out of the
way immediately that's our that's our
tendency isn't that when we have the
conflict we want to get rid of the
conflict right away suddenly actually
look at the situation and see if there
really is a conflict there and then he
says until I form the considered opinion
and then we can never have more than
that we could be wrong about this stuff
that in the circumstances one of these
duties is more incumbent than any other
that's the duty that I should go with
them and so he offers a couple ways of
thinking about this in terms of what he
calls stringency right Ross stresses
early on that there's one duty that
takes priority over all the others in
most circumstances not melfi's it's not
to do harm to people right so if keeping
a promise would result in harm to
another person then you should you know
reconsider keeping that promise this has
a greater stringency not only over
beneficence but over all the other ones
we can go a little bit further down so
we've got the most stringent
now Jesus and that we've gotta do these
lazy steps we don't have hard and fast
rules that apply in every case but we
some of our duties seem to be more
stringent than others
what are that's more perfect obligation
well Fidelis
you know if breaking a promise can
actually provide some benefit to
somebody else I still should keep the
promise I can pass up the opportunity to
helping somebody else because promises
is important its reparation you know if
I if I have to choose let's say I here
to be a great example I'd do something
that really ticked my wife off and I'm
thinking you know I could I could go buy
her flowers but I could also go down to
the bar and buy buy a round of drinks
now buying the round of drinks is gonna
make people happy right everybody likes
getting getting free stuff and that
would be beneficence and I could say I'm
fulfilling a duty well let's see how
they have a certain amount of money in
my wallet and I can either buy the
drinks or I can buy the flowers if I go
home and I tell her I was gonna buy you
flowers but I didn't because I bought
about I had water around drinks for the
guys down at the bar instead how do you
think that would fly that go over well
probably now right it's for good reasons
and then finally granted that is more
more stringent than other ones as well
the other thing the other rule that it
has is you should try to produce as much
good yes all of the things being try to
produce as much good as possible
now if it means you got to break all
sorts of promises or never you know make
up for harm that you've done but in
general you know when you've got the
chance
try to do good both for other people and
for yourself because you are worth just
as much as anybody else